[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24 y
me acompaña en el estudio marina sardina
marina bienvenida buena mañana de
miércoles vamos a hablar hoy que se
cumplen seis meses de la guerra nuclear
de ucrania con miles de muertos y
también de heridos un alto costo sobre
el sistema sanitario por supuesto de su
país y le pregunto qué ha ocurrido en
medio en este medio año en materia de
salud así es buenos diarra o la guerra
deja graves afectaciones sobre el
derecho a la salud de los ucranianos y
también sobre las infraestructuras
sanitarias dentro del país recordemos
uno de los más sonados fue el bombardeo
sobre el hospital materno-infantil el
mariupol y no es el único y es que los
centros de salud hospitales han no han
estado exentos de ataques rusos pese a
que esto constituye un crimen de guerra
y a-30 y atenta contra el derecho penal
internacional repasemos algunos datos
que ofrecen naciones unidas según el
sistema de vigilancia de ataques de las
a la salud de la onu desde el 24 de
febrero las fuerzas rusas han llevado a
cabo
473 ataques que han diezmado el sistema
sanitario ucraniano como vemos la
metralla deja casi 400 instalaciones
médicas afectadas
bombas sean golpeados 69 transportes
ambulancias afectando a unos 58 médicos
y 24 pacientes además golpeó 127
suministros y 12 almacenes dejando al
menos 98 fallecidos y más de 130 heridos
más allá de las instalaciones médicas
otra de las problemáticas del conflicto
en materia de salud de salud es la
proliferación de enfermedades víricas o
bacterianas debido al cese de las
campañas de vacunación como por ejemplo
contra el sarampión o incluso contra el
cubrir 19 que también cesaron por la
guerra los organismos internacionales
advierten de que más de 12 millones de
personas precisan de forma urgente
asistencia sanitaria y hay también raúl
una gran escasez de medicamentos
lamentables cifras marina pero no
termina ahí porque otro costo de la
guerra es la salud mental de aquellos
que la sufren cada día y por supuesto
también de los que huyen de sus hogares
así decir que la salud mental queda
siempre en estos contextos del psuv
dictó como abocado a un segundo plano el
desplazamiento la falta de alimentación
higiene personal refugio deja graves
secuelas en la mente de los
las que viven en estos contextos de
guerra como estrés postraumático
ansiedad depresión trastornos
emocionales y conductuales que incluso
pueden abocar en el suicidio para hablar
de esto tenemos con nosotros a rim ka
ricardo bango orales coordinador de
salud mental en ucrania de la
organización médicos por el mundo buenos
días de ricardo y gracias por estar con
nosotros en france 24 quería preguntarte
hay más de 6 millones de refugiados y
ucranianos fuera del país que han tenido
que huir la mayoría son mujeres niños y
ancianos cómo está la salud mental de
estas personas que han huido y que han
tenido que salir de sus hogares
las personas que han tenido que salir de
sus hogares y salir del país pero que
también hay otros un porcentaje
importante no cerca de 6 millones de
personas que están desplazadas dentro de
dentro del país
sufren las consecuencias de haber dejado
atrás sus hogares sus pertenencias parte
de sus familiares algunos incluso en el
frente de batalla y en otras ocasiones
pues a haber perdido
familiares seres queridos y tener que
reanudar una nueva vida en un contexto
completamente diferente para ellos en
muchas ocasiones estamos hablando de
familias que ya tenían su vida
completamente hecha con
con sus hijos yendo a la universidad
yendo a los colegios y de repente es su
vida se ha paralizado esto supone para
ellos un gran estrés
no solamente el estrés sino las
reacciones traumáticas que han vivido en
el país y además ese sentimiento de
pérdida que en algunas ocasiones puede
llegar a ser situaciones de duelo por la
pérdida de seres queridos ricard de un
gusto saludarlo este conflicto también
tiene un impacto devastador en los
aproximadamente 7.5 millones de menores
de edad que residen en el país cual el
costo psicológico de la guerra en estas
etapas del desarrollo cognitivo de los
menores bueno en los más pequeños
realmente lo que necesitan es la
protección por parte de sus cuidadores o
por parte de sus padres y ahí es muy
importante que los padres les protejan y
sobre todo intenten no transmitirle la
angustia y la ansiedad que ellos viven
no para sentirse protegidos y seguros
los que están en edad escolar lo que
está sucediendo en un porcentaje
importante pues es la pérdida del
interés por el juego la pérdida del
interés por las relaciones con otros
niños y con otras niñas del entorno
incluso la pérdida del interés por por
los estudios en sí no
y esto además pues se acompaña en
ocasiones con alteraciones del apetito
con alteraciones del sueño e incluso
pues en algunas ocasiones pues
regresiones después de haberse producido
un avance en su desarrollo es decir en
niños o niñas que ya controlaban sus
esfínteres pues vuelven de nuevo a mojar
la cama no y en adolescentes lo que
sucede pues es habitualmente son
alteraciones de la conducta alteraciones
del comportamiento no son en un estado
en el que se encuentra en el que se
están haciendo a sí mismos no y en esos
momentos igual sufre una situación
digamos de quiebra psicológica que les
afecta notablemente
riccardo y brevemente cuáles son las
necesidades más urgentes en materia de
salud en estos momentos para esta
población ucraniana tanto dentro como
fuera del país las necesidades la mayor
necesidad es ahora mismo porque el
sistema digamos está funcionando quizás
bueno con menos recursos que los
previamente
están de alguna manera bien organizados
pero lo que hacen falta son
fundamentalmente recursos recursos
materiales equipamiento medicamentos y
apoyo sobre todo por la gran cantidad de
heridos que hay cerca de siete mil
heridos que necesitan
intervenciones especiales para poder
atender las heridas que tienen que en
ocasiones son difíciles de tratar
riccardo gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros esta mañana de miércoles en
directo américa de france 24 un gran
abrazo desde la ciudad de bogotá
muchas gracias
ricardo angora coordinador de salud
mental en ucrania de la organización
médicos por el mundo marina también por
supuesto gracias por toda la información
referente en la materia